[Musique]
oui oui arsène qui ça holocène je ne
sais pas qui c'est moi ou la scène tu
dis qu'il faut que je t'aide sur la un
problème de rupture
comment ça c'est important et c'est une
question de vie ou de mort d'accord et
comment je fais un gros point rouge
d'accord bon bah jarrier ou la même
avait pas prévenu qu'ils auraient du
monde holocène fou puis moi aussi après
tout j'ai envie qu'on m'aide pourquoi ce
sera moi qui devrait aider les autres
j'ai rien de particulier je suis rentré
dans un jeu dont je connais pas les
règles puis les points rouges m'ont
fiche des points en jeu moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est pour une suspension ça
suce point de temps moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est c'est les points
d'interrogation c'est je sais pas après
tout ce qui m'intéresse j'en sais rien
vous savez vous c'est quoi la vérité
bon olsen m'a dit de rentrer dans le
cercle rouge et après tout se passerait
bien un humain rentrer dans le cercle
rouge
alors aujourd'hui on m'a dit il faut que
tu te fasses plaisir faut que tu te fais
plaisir et surtout il faut que tu sois
honnête avec toi et avec les autres en
tout cas que tu fasse tout pour l'être
un point rouge au sol un point rouge en
l'air et puis je fais vaille que vaille
façon maintenant 1
j'ai imaginé plein de fois ce talent des
milliers de fois je sais pas ce que je
vais faire maintenant je suis dans le
présent je suis devant vous
voilà je prends mes aises holocène bon
bah je vais trop nommé désormais tu
seras l'anthropocène et oui un humain
marche dans l'eau saine bon bah du coup
je vais me mettre à l'aise 1 puisque
c'est ce qu'ils font les humains après
tout il aime changer leur environnement
mettre des choses comme ça on avait dit
qu'on ferait on est alors en fait je
vous ai menti je m'appelle pas du tout
arsène je m'appelle théo parce que je
suis perché et ils s'en sont puisque
d'habitude j'ai l'habitude de me
raconter des histoires pas d'en raconter
aux autres
alors j'imagine alors puisqu'on m'a dit
de me faire plaisir je vais je vais
vraiment me faire plaisir et je vais
imaginer quelque chose qui s'appelle non
pas l'anthropocène mes mails à théo
scène après tout pourquoi pas on peut
très bien imaginer que l'évolution de
l'humanité
ça serait d'évoluer tels des dieux de
devenir immortel d'avoir de plus en plus
de temps et de pouvoir d'explorer
l'espace
bon ben pourquoi pas après tout alors
essayons et regardons donc je vais
dérouler le fil de mon histoire non pas
celui-là celui-là c'est le micro je suis
là et puis on va bien voir ce qui se
passe donc mon histoire à un début mon
histoire a une fin mais en vérité je
sais pas du tout ce que je vous raconte
sur mon fils qui est linéaire je sais
que peut pas revenir en arrière
je sais qu'il peut monter je sais qu'il
peut descendre mais en fait le cil il
peut aussi être circulaire il peut
s'entremêler il peut faire plein de
choses
oui bon d'accord mais si l'humanité
marche sur un fil
elle avance elle a pas le choix
et puis il faut qu'elles soient à l'aise
il faut qu'elle survive
on a coutume de dire que
la vie ne tient qu'à un fil si on
regarde ici c'est pas faux en vérité il
ya deux fils parce que si jamais on a
une rupture justement on a un système de
redondance qui permet d'éviter de
s'écraser comme une crêpe 300 mètres
plus bas mais la corde sur laquelle on a
attaché
c'est un fil ou même la plainte petit
redondance aussi mais bon passons
parce que après on est encore accrochée
à une falaise et puis il ya tout un
système d'égalisation de triangulation
mais j'ai pas envie de rentrer dans les
détails techniques il me reste 13
minutes
oulalala j'ai pas le temps j'ai pas le
temps et pourtant on en a de plus en
plus si on regarde en arrière on n'a
jamais eu autant de temps
jamais autant d'espérance de vie jamais
autant de ba de chance finalement et
donc puisque je suis dans la tsn je me
pose la question
il paraît qu'au début et elle verbe il
ya frédéric ii il a fait une expérience
sacrément perturbante d'ailleurs il
s'est dit si au début et le verbe et si
dieu existe
quelle est la langue que parlent les
humains naturellement si on leur donne
les besoins naturels d'anti dont ils ont
besoin la nourriture mais on ne leur
parle pas puisqu'il faut que le verbe
émergent
ils sont tous morts tous les bébés sont
morts
d'où l'importance de l'éducation et
d'être ensemble car l'éducation
on a envie de mordre la vie à pleines
dents mais parfois il ya des déciles
rouge aidés il ya des limites à ne pas
dépasser et le film le fils c'est
l'amour
filoche et l'amour les amis seul on
survit pas on sait pas faire mais quand
on tire trop sur la corde
parfois un effondrement
et puis on sait pas vraiment d'où ça
vient ça pourrait être devant ça
pourrait être derrière on aurait pu
anticiper tout savoir des lignes de
fracture l'éviter et puis on peut
imaginer le fils le fils qui domine le
fils qui protège et puis quand on
grandit on a envie de suivre son propre
chemin de s'élever puis on regarde
autour on essaie d'anticiper de
comprendre un peu mieux ce qui se passe
et puis arrive les problèmes et qui dit
problème des ruptures des ruptures dit
renée sance renaissance où on a beau se
prendre des claques randonnée on respire
et tout va bien mais il peut arriver des
problèmes graves
ah oui c'est vrai ah oui j'avais fait ça
aussi pour rigoler je mets tes amis
imaginer de mélanger tout média positif
parce qu'une histoire alain début elle a
une fin et puis j'avais tellement perdre
de peur de perdre le fil de mon histoire
que voilà on en est là aujourd'hui
le réchauffement climatique bon en
vérité il me semble que le réchauffement
climatique
on pourrait le résoudre on a les outils
depuis longtemps on à l'économie
circulaire l'économie bleus ont pour s
entraider peut-être davantage
il me semble qu'on peut régler ses
problèmes mais il ya peut-être d'autres
problèmes qui sont plus graves
peut-être que de l'émergence de quelque
chose qui n'existe pas pour un être une
intelligence artificielle une conscience
artificielle puisse être qu'après tout
c'est pas si grave peut-être que
l'humanité pourrait se mélanger avec
celle là puisque nos connexions
finalement ne sont pas si rapide
notre interaction avec le milieu est
plutôt lente et aujourd'hui la machine
est capable de nous battre au go n'ont
pas été capables de nous battre au go
mais elle s'est entraînée des milliards
de fois elle est capable maintenant de
bad l'intégralité ou 100 de l'humanité
au go en même temps bon passons
bienvenue dans mon monde un monde fait
d' équilibre ou en tout cas de tentative
d' équilibre ce qui est radicalement
différent l'humanité elle a évolué
suivant tout un tas d'aspects
et puis il ya environ 500 ans et eu un
bouleversement ce bouleversement c'est
la révolution scientifique
on s'est mis à dire je sais que je ne
sais rien fait alors je vais regarder un
peu là un peu l'appui v7 comprendre ce
qui se passe
et puis du coup ah ouais ouais il s'est
passé tout un tas de choses en fait
maintenant il ya des réseaux dans les
airs je crois que ça s'appelle internet
où il est fou je suis là ils se baladent
sur son fils a oui c'est vrai l'humanité
marche sur un fil c'était ça l'idée
c'était ça l'idée
mais il est plus accroché en fait mais
ça va pas non non en fait l'idée c'est
qu'il fallait regarder derrière parce qu
en fait ouais on pourrait très bien dire
sur toutes ses solutions et ses
problèmes malgré le fait qu'on a qu'on a
peur du vide on a peur de l'absence on a
peur de la mort mais peut-être que les
gens qui sont au pouvoir en fatigue
ils ont prévu des sécurités qu'on voit
pas peut-être peut-être que finalement
ce qui est important dans tout ça c'est
de traverser les fossé de l'ignorance de
d'être au dessus de l'obscurantisme de
chercher la lumière d'avancé de toute
façon on n'a pas le choix le temps passe
et je vous rappelle qu'on est sur le fil
du temps l'humanité ah ouais c'est ça
ouais donc l'humanité avance sur un fil
et en fait il a choisi consciemment de
le détacher finalement il a inventé la
bombe nucléaire
il a causé le réchauffement climatique
on est rentré dans la sixième extinction
de masse
bon il soit dit en passant là le plus
grand cataclysme plus grandes pertes de
vie à l'échelle de l'humanité c'est
l'apparition de l'oxygène en réalité ça
à recomposer la vie nous on a eu la
chance d'apparaître
en tout cas il paraît parce que il ya
beaucoup d'idées a priori si on
considère qu'il ya aujourd'hui 7
milliards 5
ça veut dire qu'il ya autant d'idées de
la réalité que deux personnes sur la
planète
en tout cas si on en croit le paradoxe
de fermi c'est à dire que autour de nous
dans l'espace il n'y aurait pas de vie
sauf si on considère les extrêmophiles
les extrêmophiles les tardigrade ceux
qui aiment l'extrême qui pourrait vivre
dans l'espace
peut-être nous aussi on pourrait faire
ça non en réalité
en réalité on peut rien prévoir en
réalité on est dans le noir on marche
sans sécurité au dessus du vide dans
noir et on n'en a pas conscience
non en fait je une sécurité derrière
bon et puis y'a un truc qui est rigolo
c'est l'entropie l'entropie les mots
j'aime jouer avec les mots parce que ça
permet de guérir les maux justement
l'entropie on sait jamais comment ça
s'écrit savourer écrira n comme le
principe entreprises qui l'homme moi je
vous laisserai chercher c'est trop
compliqué expliqué et puis la loi de
l'entropie dont on a déjà parlé ce soir
mais bon l'idée c'est de dire si on
continue d'évoluer comme ça en cherchant
la lumière
et puis que l'autre montgolfière on en
est tous ont soit des montgolfières ne
monte pas et le système n'est pas
suffisamment élastique
on va avoir une rupture à un moment
donné les suivants à l'endroit où a lieu
la rupture
on pourrait imaginer qu on se raccroche
au fil et qu'on continue de monter où on
pourrait dire ça serait sacrément
difficile mais qu'on arrive à accrocher
le fil et qu'on tombe mais met
l'intégralité de la civilisation pas une
petite civilisation comme il y en a eu
tant d'autres parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est
global on est tous ensemble
ainsi l'intégralité de la civilisation
tombe qu'on a plus d'énergie plus de feu
intérieur plus d'énergie eh bien on
tombe on tombe reste une solution on
peut sauter faire le grand saut
le grand changement de paradigme
finalement là ça voudrait dire retourner
sur terre et ça me rappelle une histoire
ça une autre histoire c'est ouais c'est
l'histoire d'une civilisation qui tombe
qui tombe qui tombe qui tombe qui tombe
qui tombe l'important c'est pas la chute
c'est l'atterrissage est donc pour
continuer la fameuse métaphore
religieuse parce que je trouve ça rigolo
on retomberait dans le jardin d'éden et
on se dirait a peut-être qu'on devrait
s'inspirer plus du vivant plutôt que de
s'en servir comme des décorations et et
de les enfermer dans des grands
abattoirs géant et sans nourrir
peut-être que c'est quelque chose à
creuser
peut-être qu'il faudrait retrouver le
fil harmonie harmoniser les tensions le
philosophie l'amour de la sagesse homo
sapiens sapiens comment ne pas aimer la
sagesse deux fois la file entropie
l'amour de l'homme bon pas la charité
parce que ça ait une illusion de
philanthropie et puis et les ruptures
c'est aussi des rencontres
et puis comment intégrer l'humanité sur
son fils sans la femme et avec cette
femme justement on a créé un projet qui
s'appelle élémentaire le but de ce
projet c'est un bateau pour créer du
lien face aux grands défis de l'humanité
sacrément vicieux comme tateo cents ans
d'histoire
je ne sais pas quoi en fait on peut pas
le faire seul
on a besoin de vous et on a besoin déjà
que vous regardiez et aussi on a besoin
de vous de vos idées et des idées tous
les autres parce que finalement pour
avancer il nous faut non pas coexister
avec l'ensemble de nos différentes
cultures
non il faut faire davantage
il faut arrêter de se battre les uns
contre les autres
il faut qu'on tout cas qu'on essaye de
trouver une ressemblance d'avancer tous
ensemble car finalement on est tous dans
le même bateau et la glace là bas elles
font elles sont vite elles font vite et
ça enchaîne des boucles et des boucles
de rétroaction et qui pourrait nous
conduire à la catastrophe
l'horloge de fin du monde
le lanceur d'alerté ultime celui que
l'on peut faire revenir en arrière mais
finalement quand ça s'arrête on sera pas
l 107e minute il y aura personne pour la
mettre sur minutes et puis de toute
façon après tout ce ne sera pas à nous
de régler ses problèmes c'est aux
futures générations et futures
générations et son nom du monde qui est
de plus en plus complexe puisque dire
qu'on ne sait rien ça veut dire
potentiellement que on admet que les
choses sont de plus en plus complexe
puisque on cherche à progresser ses
enfants ses filles elles ont trois ans
et demi elle se met déjà dans des
situations bernard que la plupart
d'entre nous ne devrait pas bon si
l'humanité marche sur un fil
chaque action que l'on fait à les
répercussions à la fois sur notre
environnement
mais l'environnement a aussi des
répercussions sur nos et l'avenir est
fait de tous les petits pas qu'on peut
faire pour continuer à avancer
et si l'homme civilisé se retrouver
véritablement dans la nature et que le
fils s'effondrait il aurait d'une part
du mal à survivre mais aujourd'hui
pourrait reconstruire une civilisation
d'autant plus vite qu'il a mis en place
des sécurités pour pouvoir psychologique
pas à physique pour pouvoir rpt
progresser très vite
l'intégralité du savoir de l'humanité
est inscrit sur des tablettes dont
plusieurs langues
il suffit d'avoir une loupe pour le lire
et puis il ya les banques de réserve
mondiale de graines ouhlala le temps
accélère vite vite il faut aller vite
vite vite
ne restez pas les bras croisés face aux
problèmes
on n'a jamais raison tout seul jamais il
faut agir
même si on sait pas quoi faire de toute
façon on n'a pas le choix on agit sur
tout et puis dans ce monde là où il n'y
a pas d'autres planètes
il va falloir trouver l'équilibré ans a
sacrément beaucoup de choses entre nous
en tant qu'individu mais avec les autres
entre le high tech et le low tech entre
tout un tas de choses
et peut-être pour aller vers quelque
chose de plus grand un plus grand réseau
plus haut à oui c'était ah oui c'était
pour vous dire qu'en fait je vous avais
pas menti il n'y avait pas de sécurité
et l'homme est vraiment en train de
marcher sur un fil
les yeux fermés et la plupart d'entre
nous n'ont pas conscience mais vous
pouvez continuer à fermer les yeux
vous pouvez regarder avec autre chose et
si on imagine que je vais poser ça parce
que ça va me gêner
la vie continue et qu'on a un problème
un noeud et qu'une crise rentrons dans
une chrysalide
inspirons-nous du vivant devenant des
papillons réglant les problèmes en
tirant sur le bon fil et continuons
d'avancer
continuons d'avancer jusqu'à ce que ben
ouais c'est vrai c'est la ligne rouge
qu'il fallait pas franchir bon eh ben
merci de m'avoir écouté je vais ramasser
mes déchets et puis je vais revenir
parmi vous parce que lego et il en a
pris un sacré coup
[Applaudissements]